are you on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's your lucky night [ __ ] you
thought it was just gonna be a ho-hum
[ __ ] Wednesday night you had no
[ __ ] idea you [ __ ]
we're going deep tonight [ __ ]
[Music]
BAM you're like what the [ __ ] just
happened one minute I'm looking at a
[ __ ] Saint with a candle uncle Joey
here reporting from the [ __ ] Church
podcast headquarters we got [ __ ]
brownies tonight oh we got a full bag
and magically sealed of stars of debt
for medical use only may cause
drowsiness how about all the other
[ __ ] symptoms and how about all the
other [ __ ] symptoms [ __ ]
we got regular 125 we got brownies
brownies brownies and more brownies we
like brownies but we're trying to cut
back on the [ __ ] fat so going deep
right off the bat so there's no
misunderstanding if you think this is a
periscope about love and whatever you
got the wrong periscope especially
tonight [ __ ] we're going deep and
we got all look at this we got [ __ ]
ape [ __ ] from perennials
we got Skywalker from perennial and
guess what else we got weed in the back
let me tell you something when they give
it to you in a bag that's when you know
[ __ ] this football look at these buds
are dead [ __ ] around tonight oh [ __ ]
I even brought an empty one and don't
matter what the label says it's all
wrong to the [ __ ] hemisphere of your
skull you know I'm saying look at this
we got more weed than the Apes [ __ ]
that's what it's called because you go
apeshit people see the devil they jump
off buildings I hope you I hope you
brought your [ __ ] rollerskates
tonight [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm gonna show them a picture nothing
understand me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] here we go
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] man oh [ __ ] it's that
time [ __ ] give your parents a
hug give your parents a hug Tom you'll
giggle you're going on a psychological
excursion with uncle Joey [ __ ] Hannibal
Lector we're going deep tonight oh [ __ ]
[Music]
that's right cuz I left them in the car
all afternoon and ninety degree weather
you understand me get nice and brittle
and [ __ ] I don't know what this one's
called but I'll tell you what someone
what it smells like me it smells like
[ __ ] up off/on pool let me get that
Saints card there there you go and God
We Trust st. Jews you lose a [ __ ] of a
jungle you say a prayer the st. Jude
boom she pops up just like that
motherfucker's you're saying Joey what's
going on over there how come nobody's
smoking I've come nobody's token I [ __ ]
nobody's losing their mind I'm happy you
ass
[Music]
the body of Christ compels you open up
is 600 philately what do you think why
not 102 oh [ __ ] green that's Filipe
uncle Joey shake for me girl Oh Phil I
wanna be your back door man I want to
sniff your [ __ ] [ __ ] from
behind oh oh oh oh you have
[ __ ] you thought the party was
at your house the party's over here
[ __ ] you come by you get a star you
understand me I'm gonna [ __ ] job and
only no tears I don't wanna hit by you
how you got molested I don't give a [ __ ]
keep it cool it baby
[Music]
that's it just like that vitamin C
minerals the whole thing star one stars
available at sunset herbals reuse now
let's get into the [ __ ] real meat
potatoes of this [ __ ] name and if I
say to you tomorrow
take my hand child come with me eat
what's up Lee you ready for another star
ever yup we got things to doing people
to say you understand before you think
the [ __ ] good alphas gonna come and
save you this is it it's Wednesday night
every man for himself abandon ship pilot
to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
[Music]
and on because the show ready here comes
Gretchen ease
[Music]
we're asking was there a time for Joey
the one I jus is in Israel's we speak
crossing borders like a [ __ ] he's
crossing borders like a Syrian refugee
he understand me
he don't give a [ __ ] he'll be in about
two weeks I got some hand he said he
said Lee's right is gonna pop out while
he smokes his latest batch it's Isis ash
it smells like dead [ __ ] feet I hate
hummus I'll be some rest dressing oh
[Music]
[ __ ] have to feel the technology facts
of this [ __ ] Reaper let me go open
the door and let the [ __ ] a little
something for the mouth just in case my
girl shows up wake up [ __ ] you
thought uncle Joey disappeared while
you're [ __ ] sleeping I'm creeping
without the cape bikini style it's a
beautiful night here in Southern
California the winds blowing oh yeah oh
yeah people this is it let's smoke a
bowl of [ __ ] apeshit and see what
that's like
listen you wanna party with the big boys
this is how we do it okay
buh football with the [ __ ] devil
look at that please about the tray of
debt that he stole from [ __ ] the
reefer tray for American Express in
France
don't leave home without one cut second
we long for big corporate sponsors if
you're big sponsoring your smoke weed
you're ready for flavor
what's up beautiful
will come right through the fence right
now what you need so bang I love you
guys are joining me tonight hey listen
this is it you want me to blow
firecrackers of my ass only pick up
Chinese I don't know no I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but I do know a little bit music
little bit of reason we park we get
together you know you can't lose it's a
winning combination
oh this is it people
you know what do you do where you going
this is what why don't you a [ __ ] about
anything or the circus oh here we go
oh [ __ ] children my head is on fire
[Music]
embarrass me like what [ __ ] a couple
days ago I might have a dinner and some
women get into an argument about women
in comedy enough nobody get spots
anymore were you there and also some
woman
I'll Sakai result I love his [ __ ]
crying she's out every [ __ ] night two
kids out there know everybody else pros
unless I gotta give her a call
say why don't you Facebook you have two
Facebooks so I lost on Kyra's Facebook
key retirement I love this job
I [ __ ] see her with a baby belly and
a den looking [ __ ] better than a
model I'm sitting on this woman's
[ __ ] gorgeous she's grown up to be a
[ __ ] Fox and then I find the other
page and it's her without the baby bald
you're [ __ ] beautiful
holy [ __ ] so all jokes aside we gotta
hear tonight she's gonna [ __ ] show
you a beauty talk about the myth about
women in comedy it's all [ __ ] funny
is funny if you have that the back of
your mind
who gives a [ __ ] understand I don't play
that [ __ ] I just look dumb that's a
corny-ass pic yeah imma spit but at the
end of the day I'm not gonna throw
I'm so sick and tired Hillman we're
gonna taking pictures of the comedy
store lineups and the improv lineups to
see how many spots go out to women and
all that time even you can do a [ __ ]
you can write a [ __ ] joke and at all
and in all that negativity you can be
doing something you know when you get
here you've way this to get into the
comedy store and for years I've seen
people [ __ ] and eat some alive it
eats difference Eisley and i'm xocai you
know what move on move on move on and
come back you never know what can happen
in the future you might get on a TV show
now they call you you've wasted three
years of anger towards Tommy or Adam
what Scott day or whoever
what Mitzi and it's not worth the
aggravation for years I saw people now
that during the week you know I'd only
gonna showcase dude you know they like
right now you could be doing a sexy
right now you're gonna be doing the set
having a good time not even thinking
about it but you're so caught up in the
Comedy Store in the last act in The
Improv a sense of set eight people and
800 people are the same in your mind get
them saying they're the same in your
mind sir I said [ __ ] one more
Bollywood let's go boy I just left the
house man and I got how long wheels I
got a three year old my god she's
[Music]
but she's cuz she don't sleep at daycare
and then she comes home with five
[ __ ] like he did ten stars can start
the Escalade she literally picked the
chair up and walked around the circle's
she didn't know what she wanted to do
and you could see she wanted to cry
because he was frustrated mentally
[ __ ] broken No so I slow it down I
take him to room going then get your
head together I come out with your
[ __ ] your heads together [ __ ]
will be on in ten minutes the church
what's happening now Cairo so proud of
its a new special Lisa I will be back
[ __ ] stay black you too